You want to get nuts
let's get nuts
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
this will be my full flash movie breakdown
Easter eggs for the entire movie there's so many
references and stuff that's happening in real life
with James Gunn's reboot that they try to tie into
the movie so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos real big spoiler warning
if you haven't seen the movie yet because we'll be
talking about everything the movie is intended to
be a bookend for the Snyder verse of characters
even though Aquaman 2 is coming out later this
year and Blue Beetle technically Blue Beetle will
be like the First new character that James Gunn
recognizes is being part of his DCU some of the
Snyder Vs DC EU actors will continue in the DCU
but they'll be like alternate universe versions of
their characters they'll retune the backstories as
they need to in the new movies there are a couple
moments in The Flash movie where they call us out
specifically so I'll Point them out as we get to
those parts of the film The quick history lesson 2
because The Flash movie of all the DC movies that
they've been doing the last many many years since
they've been doing DC movies in general has been
one of the longest running DC movies that's been
stuck in development hell since the 1980s that's
right they were going to make a Flash movie or
they tried to before they made Michael Keaton's
1989 Batman movie Very apropos because Michael
Keaton's Batman is a big part of this movie
they also released this movie almost to the day
10 years from when they released the Man of Steel
movie which is Big to the plot of the film as well
literally this week 10 years ago Henry cavill's
Superman movie came out starting the Snyder versus
movies so they're starting the Schneider verse
and ending the Snyder verse in the same week that
original 1980s version The Flash movie was going
to be written by Jeff Loeb who most you remember
as the writer of a lot of Batman's best stories
like the long Halloween eventually Adam Brody
became a version of the movie Flash in George
Miller's Justice League mortal movie in the early
2000s that fell apart then Zack Snyder eventually
came on to do the Man of Steel movie with Henry
Cavill Superman and that began the Snyder verse
where they started to make the modern Flash movie
that went through about four different directors
and was originally supposed to come out in 20 18.
remember this original schedule everybody cried
remember what we might have seen had this all
worked out until they found Andy muschietti the
director and they settled on doing a version of
Flashpoint combined with Batman into the bat first
there are so many versions of Batman in this movie
All Right freeze I'm Batman but starting at the
beginning of the movie they actually deleted a
bunch of scenes from the original opening you
probably saw in all the trailers there was a
longer scene where flash was getting his breakfast
order and the clerk makes him wait while he's
getting calls from Ben Affleck's Batman to come
help and Gotham City while he's watching Henry
cavill's Superman on the TV boys trying to figure
out where to go around the earth which Justice
League remember to help originally the movie
was about four hours long there were a bunch
a bunch of Cameo scenes from other Justice League
actors like Henry Cavill Superman scenes there was
an alternate post-credits scene just a bunch of
stuff in general that hit The Cutting Room floor
so I'll do a completely separate video about that
this weekend most of the changes they made to the
movie were because of James Gunn's re but they
kind of had to retune things so they could use
this as a bookend for Ezra Miller in the Justice
League Snyder verse in the theatrical version they
just wanted a quicker more action-packed opening
scene so they just start with him running straight
to Gotham in the new version of The Flash suit
which they gave him in a prequel comic book Ben
Affleck's Batman is is the one who created the
flash ring which is from the comics they used on
The Flash TV show a bunch of times who also made
the flash suit I think there were some deleted
scenes in the original version of the movie where
Ray Fisher's cyborg would have been part of this
too until they took him out of the film one of
the most noticeable things in the movie is the way
the flash runs too they doubled down on the Zack
Snyder Snyder verse method and he said that it's
meant to look kind of like the flash is swimming
through the speed force instead of traditional
running like Grant gustin's flash does it's one of
those love it or hate it kind of things like why
does The Flash run so weird they even joke about
it later in the movie when he loses his powers
and kind of tries to swim run around in circles
screaming one of the other noticeable things too
is with a younger version of Barry when he gets
Powers he runs normally like Grant gustin's flash
he doesn't do the weird swim running that the
older version of flash does part of the joke
there is also they want to say that this younger
Berry is theoretically or could become a better
version of The Flash than the older version of
Barry he runs normally he learns stuff way faster
he becomes even quicker as the flash like he gets
more powerful way faster and if you never realize
that Central City of the comics is located in the
midwest Gotham City is right next to Metropolis
on the East Coast which is why it looks like he
has to run so far to get the Gotham Ben Affleck's
Batman literally rolls in on his new bat cycle to
take down Carmine falcony's crew which is stolen a
deadly virus from the hospital then blasted their
way out causing the destruction that the flash has
to fix some of the upgrades with the new suit
from the Justice League movie In The Peacemaker
series is that it dissipates static energy that
the flash builds as he runs make all the static
shock jokes that you want later in the movie they
use us for a big joke with a younger version of
Barry who makes a Star Wars Emperor Palpatine
joke like the emperor from Star Wars I'll just
give it off any sort of shocking people with speed
force energy and speaking of everybody getting new
suits Ben Affleck's Batman gets a new Batman suit
this version is meant to be closer to the comics
the blue and gray suit with modern technology like
it's his suit but it's a version of the blue and
gray suit they also reveal the Flash and started
using an energy meter to measure how much energy
he has left before he needs to refuel himself by
consuming more calories they actually turn that
into a much bigger joke during the movie too the
whole idea of him being a snack hole as he said
during the Justice League film during his big save
Wally's in the speed force as he starts to lose
energy he literally breaks into a falling vending
machine to just eat as much candy as possible even
microwaving burritos which are in the middle of
falling through the sky he tells Alfred who also
has a big cameo in the movie that he's the janitor
of the Justice League when the hospital actually
collapses they make a reference to a literal baby
shower like it's showering babies and most of the
Flash's early action scene is just meant to show
you what he can do how he uses his powers in the
speed force and just for comedy in general there
were so many people posting memes of him putting
the baby in the microwave in Reverse so if you
see microwaving babies on social media that's
what it's from they wind up reusing footage of
this slow motion speed force action scene with
them all falling in the therapy dog later
for the actual end credits one of the weird
things though like if you really dig into this
slow motion action scene of him saving all the
babies especially with the microwave here is that
when he lands and reveals them to the nurse who's
still freaking out is that the microwave actually
dings reminding him to take the baby out as if he
actually turned it on while they were falling like
wait a minute were you almost accidentally gonna
microwave that baby he makes one of the Justice
League again saying that they're terrible at
dealing with mental health which is I ironic in
real life because of everything that's happened
with Ezra Miller getting in trouble with the law
having a lot of real-life mental health issues
himself my name is Ezra Miller and I am criminally
excited to be a part of the Justice League
kind of like the pot calling the kettle black and
as Batman tries to grab the virus falling off of
the bridge Wonder Woman saves them arriving with
the lasso of Truth also causing Batman to start
burying his soul like the joke from the Justice
League with Aquaman Batman starts spouting about
his innate childhood trauma says his ego's far too
big to say thank you to Wonder Woman in that using
his vast wealth to just donate money to worthy
causes would be far more effective at stopping
crime than him ever being Batman would flash also
touches the lasso of Truth causing him to start
talking about being a virgin still I think that
we're meant to be more Wonder Woman scenes that
they wound up deleting but as part of like the
Henry Cavill deleted Superman Cameo scenes and
post-credits scenes they got rid of when he goes
back to finish the scene with the Barista getting
his breakfast order the conversation that he's
in the middle of also referencing not living
in the past anymore is meant to set up Barry's
big turn in the flash point twist in the movie
there are a lot of characters in the movie that
repeat lines of dialogue like this like learn
to let it go learn when to move on don't live
in in the past because for a large portion of
the movie he is literally stuck in the past they
go to the Central City Police Department which
they featured on The Flash TV show for a long long
time he's working as a CSI now it's been a couple
years since the events of the Justice League
movie they also introduced the movie version
of Patty spivot and Albert Desmond who they
used on The Flash TV show as well during the
comics Patty spivot eventually becomes a version
of Hot Pursuit and Albert Desmond is a version
of Dr alchemy that Tom Felton played during
season three when he's examining the yellow
gloves and later in the movie both versions of
his younger selves are wearing yellow along with
the circumstances of his mother's death
all meant to be references to the reverse
flash like lots of yellow even the director
Andy muschetti did a drawing of the reverse
flash and posted it on his Instagram that's
the beauty of all this I didn't do any of it
you did the whole idea in the movie is that
reverse flash is the person who killed Barry's
mother but they never actually show reverse flash
that they never cast an actor I think if they wind
up doing more flash stuff during James Gunn's
DCU then we'll see reverse flash for real they
bring back Iris west from the Justice League movie
they make a few references to that as well sort of
canonizing those events which were deleted scenes
in the theatrical cup but they put back in for
the Snyder cut Batman sends him the CCTV footage
taken from the day his mother was killed and at
this point because he hasn't changed things the
footage doesn't pick up his father's face so his
father is stuck in prison when they flash back to
Young Barry with his mother he's wearing a yellow
Scooby-Doo t-shirt fun fact in real life James
Gunn who is now like the Kevin foggy of DC movies
and responsible for this big DC reboot wrote both
of the original live-action Scooby-Doo movies they
were like his first real big budget movies that
he worked on in Hollywood his mother also tells
young Barry not every problem has a solution
sometimes you have to let it go and learn when
to walk away one of the other many references
in the movie to him literally really having to
do this at the end of the film like learn to
walk away from this universe because you can't
save it you notice they recast his father is Ron
Livingston from the Justice League movie Billy
crudup had a scheduling conflict just because the
movie had several delays but originally he was
going to continue playing Barry's father during
the movie he also says run Berry run which is
right out of the Flash TV show Even though Grant
Gustin doesn't actually get a cameo scene that I
could spot which absolutely sucks that was one
of the only things that I really did not like
about the movie there were a couple issues I had
with it but that was one of the biggest ones about
Barry Allen no what does that means this should
be impossible now to be impossible now how do you
have all these Multiverse cameos and still not
have a Grant Gustin Cameo when they show young
bear in his room he has a Star Wars Death Star toy
the circular shape of the Death Star is meant to
be a reference to the way he perceives realities
in the speed force and Alternate universes which
he calls the Chrono Bowl the whole idea is
that each alternate universe is presented by
a different Chrono Bowl then he travels into the
speed force arriving at the chronobo you notice
that the depiction of the speed force is the same
from the Justice League Snyder cut but the way
they're treating this is that he's traveling
so fast he perceives his own timeline so like
the Chrono Bowl around him here the circular area
is just his own timeline relative to him all the
events of his life that he's seeing from the past
so for instance if Batman traveled into the speed
force like this and looked into the chronobo
he'd only see moments from his life like he'd
see his parents death in Crime Alley again the
reason why the Flash doesn't see stuff like that
is because he's only seeing moments from his own
timeline things that he actually experienced in
the past so when they have all the other cameo
scenes which I'll talk about later those are
meant to be other people's timelines completely
alternate universes they're going with kind of a
Loki explainer for how the timelines work during
the movie the way they're doing it in the Marvel
movies is that some timelines are closely related
like in the Marvel movies it looks kind of like
Batman's spaghetti explainer one of the few things
I didn't like about their explanation for how time
travel works at least in the DC EU here for this
movie is the way that him changing the timeline
say his mother's death also affects moments from
before that in the timeline you could do like 10
different videos just about how time travel works
because in real life it's still theoretical so
there are a bunch of scientists arguing about what
the correct explainer for time travel would be
they make a lot of back to the future references
in the movie too because the plot is very similar
to The Back to the Future plot but in the Marvel
movies they also call Out Back to the Future as
a very poor explainer for how time travel really
works later Batman also says the same thing too
like you probably saw a movie where someone
explained how time travel works but that was
wrong that was meant to be a dig at the Back to
the Future movies for how time travel works like
no no it wouldn't work like that in real life the
better way to think about it in the movie because
we're talking about DC in the DC Universe they
have a concept called hyper time which is like
the sum total for all possibilities any different
number of timelines per the Batman man's spaghetti
explainer he causes a bunch of those timelines
to overlap so not everything from those original
timelines is the way that it used to be in their
original timelines so it's Michael Keaton Batman's
timeline overlapping with Supergirl's timeline
overlapping with Henry cavill's Superman timeline
overlapping with the main Justice League timeline
just a bunch of Justice League timeline soup when
he tells Batman what he's done going back in time
a day he gives him the whole Flashpoint explainer
like this is why you do not do that because you
will destroy everything which he almost winds
up doing he literally almost causes the entire
Multiverse to collapse on itself by the end of the
film you notice he offers to save Batman's parents
from being killed by Joe Chill in Crime Alley then
Batman tries to explain how the tragedy defined
him and helped him to become a better person like
I would never become Batman and because of all
the good things that I do as Batman the world
is ultimately a better place and if you undid that
I would have never become Batman so theoretically
things would be way worse a lot of this is out of
the comic book version of Flashpoint the original
version they did a Justice League Flashpoint
movie which was pretty close to that comic book
version too one of the big similarities between
Batman and Flash are that they both lost their
parents when Iris West comes to visit him at his
apartment there's an Easter egg for the It movie
and Pennywise in the background Andy muschetti got
his job on The Flash movie because of his work on
both it movies you notice in his fridge he's got
a big belly Burger cup that's a big chain in DC
Comics they featured it in all the arrowverse
TV shows and they just had a big belly Burger
Easter egg during the Blue Beetle trailer the
poster on his wall here is from the movie 1
Million BC which is just a reference to his time
travel into the past then when he travels back
into the past to save his mother there's a Henry
Cavill Cameo scene from the Justice League movie
several Cameo scenes and scenes from the Justice
League Snyder cut where they're all fighting him
at his statue along with Aquaman Ben Affleck's
Batman also from the events of that movie there
was a small retcon to the Justice League Snyder
cup you may have noticed here when he visits his
father at iron Heights Prison which is also from
the comics during the movie they swapped in Ron
Livingston so that it all makes sense like
oh yeah Ron Livingston has always been his
father as he continues traveling back along his
own timeline he sees his hard suit from Justice
League his very first Proto flash suit which you
see in a flashback later in the movie this was
the original accident that gave him his powers
and he's traveling basically to the early 2000s
about 20 years ago he puts the can of tomatoes in
his mother's shopping cart so that she won't wind
up needing them and won't wind up being killed and
as he travels Back to the Future to make another
back to the future reference he gets pushed out
of the speed force by the dark flash exactly 10
years ago saying that he did it this way because
he wanted to force Barry to create him create a
bootstrap Paradox where he caused his own creation
the movie is referring to him as dark flash but
he's basically like a savitar version of Barry
he's meant to be the alternate future version
of this younger Berry who just kept trying to
find different ways to save Supergirl and his
mother from Zod for hundreds and hundreds of years
but the reason why his speed Force lightning has
become purple is just because he's gotten more
powerful faster as he's gotten older his crazy
looking suit is meant to be the accumulation
of Kryptonian weapons and plating that's been
embedded in his body through all the different
battles he's had across the hundreds of years
it's also meant to be partially inspired by the
look of the Daniel West reverse flash from The
New 52 who looked like a more monstrous version
of The Flash so he punches him out of the speed
force to exactly 10 years ago to the week as Zod
is attacking during the events of the Man of Steel
movie and a few hours before he initially got his
powers he's playing on the idea that this version
of Barry will feel compelled to help his younger
self get powers not knowing whether or not it will
affect his powers in the future but the thing
is he would have totally been fine not giving
the younger Berry Powers because remember when he
changed the past he created a branch timeline so
he would have been able to keep his powers they
have a couple jokes about this when he's trying
to figure it out like will this affect me in the
future I don't know let's not worry about it I'll
just give myself Powers just to be safe going to
have dinner with his parents again is also right
out of the Flash TV show where Grant gustin's
flash is able to have dinner with his parents
again in the past the spaghetti this time is
also meant to be foreshadowing for Batman's
spaghetti explainer later in the movie when
he meets his younger self notice he's wearing
yellow more reverse flash Easter eggs even though
he's not really in the movie and in his bedroom
because this is 10 years ago there's movie posters
from around that period like a Christopher Nolan
Inception poster because that movie would have
come out around this time also Christopher Nolan
in real life did The Dark Knight Batman Trilogy
with Christian Bale and he was executive producer
helping Zack Snyder on the Man of Steel Superman
movie which is Big to the plot of this film the
reason for the Pacific Rim poster is because it
came out around this time too but also in real
life Andy muschietti got a big help from Guillermo
del Toro who took him under his wing and helped
him make his very first movie in Hollywood so he's
honoring him with a small reference when younger
Barry asks if he has a plane that goes underwater
or a boat that can fly that's a reference to both
Batman's vehicles from George Clooney's Batman
and Robin the bat boat because he travels to
this universe at the end of the movie as well you
can also think of it as a reference to Michael
Keaton's new bat jet which also flies through the
waterfall where does he get those wonderful toys
when he recreates the original accident that gave
him Powers using the same storm same lightning
bolt he gets struck again taking his powers
away they also use the tooth falling out joke at
the end of the movie again with George Clooney's
Batman but the difference is is that at the end of
the movie he still has his powers so it falls out
just because of the stress of realizing that he
messed up the timeline again like oh my God who's
this guy you're not Batman oh no what have I done
by the events of the post-credits scene short
time Jump later his tooth has grown back just
confirming that he still has his powers on this
alternate earth when they go back to this other
barriers apartment you notice on the computer
monitor nearby there's a Looney Tunes picture
that's mostly meant to play play into the whole
dark flash twist with a roadrunner Wiley Coyote
relationship and Speedy Gonzales which he makes a
joke about right after this while he's testing his
powers zoom in enhance you also notice there's a
Mars Attacks poster behind him which is meant to
be a reference to Zod in the kryptonians attacking
from the other planet then they start making the
Back to the Future movie joke setting up the
way that he's changed this timeline with all
the Eric Stoltz references it's a huge deep cut in
real life because Eric Stoltz was originally cast
as Marty McFly in that first Back to the Future
movie he filmed a bunch of the movie then they
fired him and hired Michael J fox to replace him
when Zod attacks he has another flashback scene
explaining what he was doing during the events of
the Man of Steel movie they kind of did a version
this during the beginning of Batman v Superman
with Ben Affleck's Batman to explain what he was
doing while that was happening he also explains
Henry cavill's Superman and what happened with
the dceu version of the Man of Steel movie like we
need to find Superman he can take care of Zod and
the kryptonians turns out he is way more powerful
than all these flashes Batman and Supergirl all
put together because probably one of the biggest
twists of the movie is that no matter what they
do all of them are not powerful enough to stop
Zod during the movie even though it gets really
serious in the second half of the film they make a
lot of references to this too like Henry cavill's
Superman being the Giga Chad version of Superman
we really need him he's the person that can solve
all these problems when he meets younger Barry's
roommates they're all his friends from the dceu
Patty's pivot Albert Desmond and Gary but they're
all just way more chill versions of the characters
he learns cyborg hasn't become cyborg yet he's
still a football player at Gotham City University
the Wonder Woman they use for this joke here seems
familiar but I couldn't spot her if you think
you know who this is just write it below in the
comments the magic with the rabbit in the Hat is
also Zatanna reference you notice Albert Desmond
is wearing a Gremlins 2 t-shirt but because this
is an alternate universe one of the things that
they changed is that in the Gremlins movie it says
you're not supposed to feed them after 12 p.m noon
instead of feeding them after midnight there's a
cameo scene from tamura Morrison's Thomas Curry
reprising his role from the Aquaman movies but
in this reality he never met Atlanta his mother
and he wound up naming his dog Arthur which is an
Indiana Jones reference we named the dog Indiana
then they reveal Michael J fox is the person who
starred in Footloose here instead of Kevin Bacon
and Kevin Bacon starred in Top Gun as Maverick but
they never actually say which movies Tom Cruise
wound up doing in this reality they reveal they
do know about Batman with Patty spivot repeating
the line from the movie I'm Batman and burping
from the 1989 film setting up the joke later
when Michael Keaton repeats it here you are yeah
I'm Batman where are you I'm Batman when they
arrive at the Wayne Mansion it's designed exactly
like Michael Keaton's Wayne mansion from his
movies but they're treating it like only the
Batman 1989 movie and Batman Returns are Cannon
to his character in Batman Forever with Val Kilmer
Batman and Robin with George Clooney are both
totally alternate universes like we visit one at
the end of the movie when they enter the Mansion
they start playing the classic Danny Elfman Batman
theme music in the hallway that they walk through
is meant to be all the same armor suits that they
walk through during the Batman 1989 movie the
song that he's listening to on the record player
is 25 or 6 to 4 by Chicago from the 1970s because
his Batman would have been a teenager in the 70s
like the younger Berry is still a teenager during
this movie they also have a funny joke about him
painting in his retirement but like super creepy
looking paintings like ah looks really weird there
the kitchen is meant to look exactly like it did
during the 1989 Batman movie when they had dinner
there and the servant bells are a reference
to his Alfred from those movies when they
make the Downton Abbey reference to the reason
why younger Barry doesn't recognize the show is
because it hasn't been created yet that didn't
debut till later in our own real life timeline
they do have a joke about Arby's in this universe
being called Abby's like I could really go for
some Abbeys right now during the movie Michael
Keaton also wears an ascot that's meant to be
a reference to Adam West's Batman who also has a
cameo later during the big Multiverse speed force
scenes they explained what they did to Batman and
Batman basically explains how Flashpoint really
works with the spaghetti in a bowl like you're
causing all these timelines to overlap eventually
it's going to cause the Multiverse to collapse on
itself which it almost does later in the movie all
the Superman jokes they make confirmed there was
never Superman on Michael Keaton Batman's Earth
even though back in the 90s after John Wesley's
ship's Flash TV show started they did a classic
Justice League with all those characters at the
time but they never actually filmed any scenes
together when he mentions super Batman that
character actually exists in the comics it was
part of a DC a comic book story like their version
of what if Comics called speeding bullets and it's
the story of what if Superman's pod crashed in
Gotham on the Wayne's property before they can
see Bruce Wayne they wind up being the ones to
adopt alien baby Superman raise him the way that
they originally raised Bruce Wayne even though
now he never existed they're eventually killed
in Crime Alley giving this new Superman character
his origin story becoming a version of Batman so
he never becomes Superman he just becomes
a version of Batman with all the powers of
Superman so he's a little bit more like the evil
version of Superman like the hardcore Superman
and the Justice League Snyder cut that winds up
working with Darkseid because of the anti-life
equation except he's not evil he just very very
dark like the 90s version of Batman like imagine
a Batman who's Invincible basically think about
how crazy how far he would go if he knew he were
Invincible even though Batman in the comics right
now without superpowers also acts very cavalierly
with his life like he acts like he will never die
that's one of the cool things about the character
it's kind of like Daredevil in the Marvel Comics
people that don't have super powers but also
aren't worried about killing themselves and the
other thing you guys may remember if you haven't
watched that Batman 1989 movie in a while is
that when he's making fun of Superman for calling
himself a Superman there were jokes in the Batman
1989 movie about Batman calling himself a bat man
the way that Michael Keaton explains it after the
events of the Batman Returns movie he continued
having Adventures But ultimately wound up doing
his job so well Gotham became one of the safest
cities in the world and no longer needed them
to be Batman so we just went into retirement for
years making these weird paintings and listening
to 70s music when they call him the best detective
in the world that's a reference to Batman and the
comics being called the world's greatest detective
Batman also explains that he ultimately wound
up being alone so I think the idea is that if
he did get back together with Selena Kyle at some
point because she survived the events of Batman
Returns maybe she died during one of their future
adventures together but at some point long ago he
was left alone they did do some Burton verse
comics for his adventures after the events of
Batman return so they did kind of get into some
of the story of what he did in the future and
when I do my big deleted scenes video I'll talk
about the plans that they had to do a Batman
Beyond movie like a live-action Batman Beyond
movie for Michael Keaton's Batman but they've
canceled that since then they go to his Batcave
which is meant to be an upgraded version of the
original one from those original movies they play
more of his classic Danny Elfman Batman music and
when the lights turn on a bunch of bats fly out
just like I did in the Batman 1989 movie they
do that in all the Batman movies though and all
the different versions of their bat caves there's
always a swarm of bats that just flies out he's
still got the exact same Batmobile but some of
his Tech he's upgraded over the years like all
of his bad suits the back computer has been more
modernized his bat jet is new they even make the
obligatory joke about the Batmobile parking space
they've made several jokes about this all over Pop
Culture since that original Batman movie came out
like should we put a rail going around this like
is this kind of dangerous there's just a giant
Abyss here that goes to Nowhere when he says there
are tens of thousands of Clark Kents in the United
States that he's trying to weed through looking
for Superman that's meant to be a reference to
Superman's whole method for staying Anonymous
why he chose the name Clark Kent because it's
so common it'd just be easier to hide himself on
official forms and when he says he's searching in
Kansas over the past 50 years that's a reference
to the Christopher Reeve Superman movie they
originally started developing the Christopher
Reeve Superman movie about 50 years ago in 1973
didn't wind up releasing it till several years
later though younger Berry winds up finding the
Joker's bag from the Batman 1989 movie in that
movie it was meant to be a reference to Joker's
last laugh like literally and metaphorically
he had the last laugh turns out Michael Keaton
Batman just kept it for all those years all
versions of Batman though keep memorabilia from
their adventures and their takedowns in the bat
cave let the giant Penny the dinosaur the comic
book Batcave is enormous Miss there's tons of
memorabilia all over it when he falls asleep in
the Batmobile with all the Twinkies he's eaten
that's also a bit of a funny reference to the
hostess branded Batman comics that they did back
in the day they used to do brand tie-ins for DC
Comics all comics in general way back in the day
when he's holding the pen that's also a reference
to the pen that Alfred gave Michael Keaton's
Batman during the events of those movies and
when he opens his suit Vault the key is behind a
picture of his parents but just starting with all
of his suits here the one in the center is the one
that you see him actually wearing in the trailer
it's just meant to be his most advanced suit that
he has so far for the most part they're all meant
to be based on his same design language from the
1989 Batman suit that's meant to be the one in the
back left here the one on the back right is the
one he wore in Batman Returns on the far left here
super deep cut this is meant to be a version of
his very first suit like his Batman year One suit
and the Batman symbol is also different from the
others if he couldn't tell all the other Batman
suits have the same sim on it except for this one
this is meant to be the Adam West Batman symbol
from the 1966 TV series the pistols are also meant
to be grappling hooks not actual guns according to
the costume designer for the movie he also said
he designed the ears for this cowl based on the
Golden Age original Batman cowl from the comics
so it's like Michael Keaton's version of Robert
Pattinson's Batman year 2 suit a very low-fi early
prototype for what would become his 1989 Batman
suit and other future suits speaking of which for
those of you that always wanted to see Batman in
the movies where the blue and gray suit from the
comics the one right behind this is the blue and
gray suit from the comics Ben Affleck's Batman
also wears his own version of that in present
day earlier in the movie the next one on the
back right is another huge deep cut for the
Batman Returns movie it's the underwater Batman
suit that they sold as a toy but he never wore
in the actual movies it was just one of the many
many toys that they sold as merchandise speaking
of which the last one on the far right isn't
actually a desert suit even though you see the
goggles there it's actually another one based on a
toy they sold from the Batman Returns movie called
The Arctic armor bad suit and it was just for cold
environments or cold-based villains like Mr Freeze
raise your hand if you spent all your money on
all those Batman toys when those movies came out
back in the day [Music] toys they do pretty much
the same thing for every Batman movie but it was
just special back in the day there were so many
toys if you watch the behind the scenes features
they talk about all the merchandising they did
for those movies they made so much money on the
toys for those first couple of Batman movies part
of the reason for them doing such weird deep Cuts
though is to tell you what happened to Michael
Keaton's Batman after the events of Batman Returns
when they learn about Supergirl being captured by
the Russians and is being held prisoner this is a
combination of the original Flashpoint story and
Superman red Sun which is basically an else World
story about what if Superman's pod had landed
in the Soviet Union and he was raised by them
instead of the United States during the original
Flashpoint story it was the U.S government that
found Superman's pod and held him captive
underground for all those years until they
rescue him Batman says one of his other iconic
lines from the 1989 movie you want to get nuts
let's get nuts
come on let's get nuts they have another reference
to the Batman 1989 movie when they exit the Jet
and it illuminates the moon the way that it did
in the original movie really cool in this movie
and it was really cool in the original Batman
movie there's so many Easter eggs and references
that they make like lines of dialogue or just
funny jokes that they call back to from the 1989
Batman movie like when he's carrying people in the
grappling hook asking them about their weight how
much do you weigh about 108 I think hold on when
Elderberry starts throwing up after younger flash
moves in at super speed that's also a reference
to diggle doing that every single time that they
do that on The Flash TV show when they enter
Supergirl's prison you notice that her Supergirl
symbol is the exact same as Henry cavill's symbol
because they are both from the house of L it's the
same symbol for their entire house they explained
that her backstory is pretty close to the original
comic book backstory like she's meant to be older
than Cal L Henry Cavill Superman he was a baby
when she's about this old she came to Earth in
a pod to protect him and he was meant to be much
younger but in this new universe Assad was able to
intercept Superman's pod before it arrived killing
baby Superman so R.I.P to Henry Cavill Superman in
the Codex from the Man of Steel movie was actually
stored in Supergirl's DNA in this timeline so
they needed to harvest it from her the whole
thing with the Batman tape measure I think is just
a joke about all the Batman gadgets and toys and
merchandise that they sold during the 1989 Batman
movie seriously there were so much merchandise
and so many Batman gauges all the way through the
Joel Schumacher era Batman through George Clooney
and Val Kilmer's versions of Batman they also kind
of did this during the Adam West version of Batman
where like everything just had a Batman name
Supergirl gains enough temporary strength from
the Sun to save them but then passes out because
she's still super weak from all those years in
captivity under the red sunlight that they would
bombard her with during the movie she never quite
becomes as powerful as Henry Cavill Superman
primarily because he'd spent all those years
on Earth soaking in the yellow sun radiation and
Superman really doesn't have much of a limit on
how much he can soak he's kind of like a solar
battery basically so when he fought Zod he was
way more powerful because Zod had just arrived on
Earth and this is a big twist in the movie and one
of the reasons why they can't defeat them because
Supergirl doesn't become quite as powerful as odd
of the other kryptonians if she'd had a little bit
more time to soak in more solar radiation like a
couple more years she probably could have taken
them down much more easily even though she does
die during the events of this movie that's meant
to be an alternate universe completely the arm
making a Supergirl move movie now based on the
woman of Tomorrow comic book as part of the DCU
the connected movies but they haven't said whether
or not Sasha Kanye will come back as that version
of Supergirl then Barry recreates the accident
that gave him powers and it's meant to be exactly
like the original Flashpoint comic book story they
did it in the flashpoint Justice League movie as
well too where he tries to shock himself almost
kills himself doesn't work the first time and has
to do it a second time during the movie you notice
that they also use the bat jet to Aid in shocking
him in the second time Supergirl winds up carrying
him directly into the path of the storm in the sky
Batman's whole speech about the death of his
parents is meant to be similar to Ben Affleck
Batman speech earlier in the movie he gives one of
his old Batman suits from the Batman Returns movie
the slightly more armored versions to youngberry
to protect himself from those lightning strikes
when they're trying to give older barriers
powers back which he then later Fashions into
a homemade flash suit they reference Superman's s
symbol which is basically a scene directly taken
from the Man of Steel movie about meaning
hope do you know what the symbol stands for
Supergirl means hope right oh yeah it
doesn't mean hope yes it's not an ass
on my world it means hope Barry calls them the
Justice League even though they're short a goddess
for Wonder Woman a super mermaid for Aquaman in
the friendly Terminator is meant to be cyborg
when younger Barry jokes about taking pictures of
Supergirl to show their children someday I think
the idea is that at this point he's sort of Fallen
a little bit for Cara's Supergirl and he intends
on marrying her instead of Iris West like our
children which is why she kind of Riley Smiles at
the cockpit like haha yeah whatever then when they
start fighting Zod and the kryptonians pretty much
in every version of the battle ultimately they
wind up losing to them with one of them either
killing Supergirl taking the Codex from her body
so they can rebuild Krypton after terrifying the
planet but Batman also winding up dying somehow
either sacrificing himself or someone killing
him younger Barry winds up making that Star Wars
Emperor Palpatine reference when shocking people
with his speed Force lightning and they're meant
to be the exact same kryptonians from the Man of
Steel movie if it wasn't obvious because some of
the big ones do come back directly most notably
Zod feora and the big one is a version of non the
way they're explaining the balance of power in the
movie though is that despite all the Flash's
abilities both of their abilities short of
slaughtering all the kryptonians by vibrating
their hands into their hearts or their brains
they can't really kill the kryptonians they
can only slow them down the longer the battle
goes on the more powerful the more unkillable the
kryptonians become that's why during the original
Man of Steel movie Henry Cavill Superman was
able to beat them because he arrived just as
they hit the planet before they had time to soak
up enough energy to become so much more powerful
or as powerful as he was so the real lesson here
is that you needed to fight them much earlier in
the timeline it takes a few Mulligans from this
battle for older Barry to realize what everyone's
been telling him throughout the entire movie about
not finding a solution for every single problem
and learning when to walk away from things younger
Barry has not learned this lesson yet because he's
still a brand new baby Flash and because of the
way their time travel Works in this speed force
area hundreds of years maybe even thousands of
years go by he's is countless years that you can't
even imagine Tilly just ages into the dark flash
older version of Barry like the savitar version of
himself while they're coming to this realization
in the background of this Chrono Bowl speed force
the red tearing is the Multiverse beginning to
break down this is where we start to get all the
major Cameo scenes that everybody's going crazy
about on social media all the different universes
are represented by different colors different
Globes the colors themselves are based on the
Green Lantern spectrum of emotions like green
red yellow white blue violet even though we
don't see any Green Lanterns in the movie anywhere
I think there were some Green Lanterns as part of
the script before James Gunn rebooted the universe
and they removed a whole bunch of the footage but
the Violet universe is the one that the berries
are in right now the first Cameo scene starts
with the black and white Universe it's meant to be
George Reeves Superman also in it is a version of
Jay Garrick played by Teddy Sears why is it Teddy
Sears and why is it a CG version of him instead of
archive footage I have no idea one of my biggest
his complaints about the movie is that all these
Cameo scenes could have been done using archive
footage instead of really crappy looking CG during
their scene and during all the other cameo scenes
they also play archived footage from episodes or
from movies depending on what the Cameo scenes
are the blue universe is for Christopher Reeve
Superman and Helen Slater's Supergirl confirming
those two characters those two movies were
connected they also play a little bit of John
Williams Superman theme during that the yellow
universe is for Adam West Batman they play audio
from him speaking in episodes and from his Joker
laughing the green universe is for Nicholas
Cage's Superman and this is a huge deep cut
you'd only know about it if you've been following
all the Superman movies development over the past
30 plus years even the canceled Superman movies
during the late 90s Kevin Smith wrote a Superman
movie for Tim Burton called Superman lives with
Nicholas Cage playing Superman they got pretty
far into production before it was canceled there
was a huge documentary about it called The Death
of Superman lives you can go watch it right now
during the Cameo scene he's fighting a giant robot
spider because in the original movie script
he was fighting a giant robot spider and the
funny reason for this is ridiculous as it seems
the big villain in the movie being a giant robot
spider at the time the producer on the movie was
John Peters and he was obsessed obsessed with the
idea of Superman fighting a giant robot spider
later they wound up using it in the wild wild
west movie which is why at the end of that film
you see them fight a giant robot spider the way he
fights the giant spider and the little spiders all
over his body is meant to be taken directly from
the concept art developed for that movie I can
only imagine Kevin Smith just going crazy in the
movie theater when he saw this like oh my God this
is amazing they never wind up showing who was in
the red universe so I'm gonna assume that that was
meant to be Grant gustin's flash Universe for the
arrowverse it actually winds up being the younger
alternate version of himself that winds up taking
care of his older self like the savitar version
the dark flash version of them sacrificing himself
to save the main Flash and because dark flash
is basically the older version of that younger
Berry they both wind up canceling each other out
essentially so the whole idea is that the dark
flash dies at the end of this movie he's erased
from existence so technically he never existed
that means that in that particular timeline that
version of Barry winds up dying Zod takes over
that Earth Supergirl died Michael Keaton's Batman
died and that Universe just continues on in its
own timeline R.I.P to that version of Earth the
main flash travels back to his original timeline
trying to undo what he did Saving his mother so
ultimately she does wind up dying like he takes
the can of tomatoes out of his mother's shopping
cart as he says goodbye he makes another smaller
change to the Past by moving the can of tomatoes
that his father got to a higher shelf so the CCTV
camera footage will pick up his father's face
exonerating him in present day during his trial
so he'll get out of prison once he gets back
to his apartment in present day where he left
everything seems exactly the same as it was as his
apartment as he rushes to the courthouse to watch
his father be exact honored hoping that it'll work
this time he passes by director Andy muschietti in
another Cameo scene stealing his hot dog then
when his father's exonerated when he goes to
the courthouse steps with Iris West he tells the
reporter it's basically a version of his story
about the spaghetti the timelines that Michael
Keaton Batman told him earlier basically telling
all the reporters in broad daylight exactly what
happened without getting into too much detail like
here's what I did changing the timelines but
using very vague spaghetti terms he gets the
date with Iris West finally it is Batman calls
him to come celebrate with him like Hey this is
wonderful his voice on the phone sounds almost
the exact same and as he pulls up in that same
custom Mercedes-Benz Maybach outsteps George
Clooney's Batman from Batman and Robin there
was a huge reaction in my theater the first two
times I watched this I saw at a couple different
screenings and both times people went crazy when
George Clooney's face showed up Barry winds up
dropping an F-bomb like who the hell is this guy
he says Batman out loud not quietly in Broad day
like there's reporters walking all around them
and he's like wait a minute you're not Batman and
George Clooney's Batman kind of leans in knowingly
like yes of course I'm not Batman smiling at him
like please stop telling everybody that I'm
Batman and there'll be some questions about
this too because Barry's tooth falls out again so
I know people will be like wait a minute does that
mean that he lost his powers again like he lost
him when he got stuck in that other alternate
timeline this time it's meant to be more of
a joke like he still has his powers because
clearly he talks about them during the actual
post-credits scene but the idea is that you can
hurt the flash badly enough that it wounds him and
takes time for him to heal his tooth is Fine Again
by the events of the post credit scene so the
idea is that he just experiences so much acute
stress so quickly like oh my god what have I done
I've done it again that his tooth falls out the
credits themselves start and during the main part
of the credits it's just meant to be a version of
his save from the beginning of the movie where
he's rescuing all the babies and the dog at the
hospital in the speed force in slow motion with
the credits playing while everything is falling in
slow motion the actual post credit scene happens a
short while later like short time Jump with Barry
drinking at a bar with Jason momoa's Aquaman near
his apartment which is the same as his original
apartment like it's the same basic place where
he lives he says he can't get drunk because of
the way his powers work which is accurate they
had jokes about this during The Flash TV show
in the first couple of episodes and he's been
trying to explain everything that happened with
Flashpoint during the previous part of the movie
to Aquaman but he's gotten super drunk so he can
barely understand him he keeps mumbling to Barry
about getting him more drinks like get some more
drinks and gives him one of his Atlantean Rings
which Barry says is Atlantean treasure like I
can't give this to the barkeep because it's
worth so much money it's Priceless confirming
that this alternate universe Aquaman like this
Aquaman from another timeline is just like the
one from the Justice League or like the original
Aquaman Barry says they're almost home and then
he falls face down in a puddle saying no no this
is my home because he's in water very very dirty
puddle water with an exasperated Berry just kind
of throwing his hands off like ah okay whatever
and even though things seem pretty chill in this
new amalgam time like this new spaghetti timeline
that he accidentally created with a lesser version
of Flashpoint just to be clear they're not saying
that Jason momoa's Aquaman always became Aquaman
on George Clooney Batman's Earth is a situation
like happened previously in the movie where
a bunch of different people's timelines all
start overlapping together in the idea of this new
timeline soup that he created this new alternate
universe alternate timeline things aren't quite as
chaotic yet I know there'll be tons of questions
about what this means about the future of The
Flash and what's happening with these characters
is it going to try and change things again even
though it seems like it's just meant to be a funny
bookend to everything the idea is that for the
foreseeable future this main flash here is gonna
stay in this new alternate timeline he created
by Saving his father and just learn to accept
all the minor changes like I guess I just have to
live with this weird alternate version of Batman
okay whatever because it does seem like he's still
friends with this Earth's version of the Justice
League but just to be clear he's not going to go
back and undo his father's exoneration just to get
back to that original Justice League Earth that
he left from at the beginning of the movie so he
still has his powers but he's basically stuck
of his own accord he chooses to stay in this
new reality there'll be a lot of talk about this
too because originally there was a very different
ending with a very different post-credits scene
involving Henry Cavill Superman Flash getting
warnings while he was in the speed force about
a coming crisis on infinite Earths across the
Multiverse that was what a lot of those Cameo
scenes earlier in the movie with the collapsing
Multiverse was meant to set up I'll talk about
that alternate ending all those deleted scenes
and some of my bonus videos this weekend because
the movie started out being like four hours long
and they're originally way more cameos way more
Justice League stuff way more Multiverse stuff
sending out future movies like Man of Steel 2
with Henry Cavill Superman Wonder Woman three and
all that changed at the last minute after James
Gunn was hired last year and decided to reboot
DC movies so they had to make a bunch of edits
so in the version of the movie that you'll all
see in theaters they wanted this Flash movie to
end in a way that would explain how you now ever
see the Ezra Miller flash again if they decide
to recast and not bring it back in the future if
you spotted any other Easter eggs or references
during the movie that I didn't talk about in the
video just write them Below in the comments you
could watch this like a billion times and still
find more references but it's not quite as dense
with Easter eggs and references is Spider-Man
across the spiderverse I still think that's the
reigning champ in terms of Easter eggs my videos
for all the alternate endings deleted scenes
alternate post credit scenes we'll post this
weekend make sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that click here for my full post
credit scene video and click here for that deleted
scenes video I'll update the link as soon as I
post that thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!